tokio
diese kisten werden das wertvollste und
so einiges gewichtige was malerei heute
zu bieten hat
es ist die erste werk ausstellung in der
schweiz kuratiert von hans ulrich obrist
den großen zampano unter den kuratoren
die bedeutendsten werke gerhard richters
reisen wie popstars zu den wichtigsten
kunst bühnen der welt
die ankunft einer diva namens petit für
sam keller direktor der fondation
beyeler ist sie die mona lisa der
modernen malerei durch ob ist erfährt
richter ständig vom fortschritt des
aufbaus seit 27 jahren sind ob ist und
richter befreundet serie wirkt sie
steiler hang ich mal wieder mit dem
treffer erhält das modell baut das
modell paar weniger die zwei modell
wirklich einen an tapas überarbeitet und
soweit sich der umstieg wirklich war ja
nach und nach entwickeln
der blick durch das glas objekt zwölf
scheiben bricht die vier abstrakten
bilder mit dem titel bach noch einmal in
gespiegelte facetten rund 170 gemälde
und objekte die umfangreichste richter
ausstellung die in der schweiz je
gezeigt wurde
die räume sind ideal fast jedenfalls
wäre nicht ausgerechnet unter richters
berühmter kerze ein feuerlöscher
ähnlich wie john cage nach dem
zufallsprinzip komponiert lässt sich
richter in seinen abstrakten werken vom
zu verleiten
was das malen nicht einfacher sondern
schwieriger macht am anfang kann ich
theoretisch darauf schmieren dass ich
will und dann dann erst ist als
irgendein zustand auf den ich reagieren
muss und den verändern oder zerstören
muss bissig dem resultat carbon nichts
mehr zu tun ist wo nach meinem level
nichts mehr falsch ist
richter wechselt ständig seine stile der
oktober zyklus basiert auf zeitungs
bildern seine neuesten werke sind
digital entstanden wie die strips
daneben gibt es einen zyklus übermalte
fotos wie auch eines von hans ulrich
obrist
und dann natürlich gegenständliche
malerei wie die berühmte betty nach
einem foto von richters tochter
natürlich
es steckt viel liebe zum detail in der
ersten großen werkschau p hat richters
in zeitgenössische kunst interessiert
der sollte diese ausstellung nicht
verpassen